on parler de souveraineté alimentaire
c'est justement le thème de notre second
débat avant de donner la parole à nos
experts en décortique les les
propositions des candidats de ces des
candidats sur ce thème avec jonathan du
ps
la guerre en ukraine est venue
chambouler les programmes des candidats
à l'élection présidentielle à 38 jours
du premier tour en plein salon de
l'agriculture tous ou presque se sont
positionnés sur le thème de la
souveraineté alimentaire afin de limiter
la dépendance française à certaines
filières de production russe comme le
blé la crise russo ukrainienne met en
évidence une chose c'est que nous devons
être souverain en matière accompagne la
ferme france c'est un ours est majeur et
on ne peut pas la faire décroître on ne
peut pas la réduire au contraire jeunes
agriculteurs que l'agriculture a un
avenir la candidate d'extrême droite
marine le pen défend quant à elle une
vision proche sans préciser les contours
de ces mesures elle plaide pour
davantage de souveraineté en matière
énergétique et alimentaire selon elle
l'autonomie de ces deux secteurs et la
garantie de l'indépendance française
les agriculteurs de toutes les manières
possibles parce qu'il en va de la
souveraineté alimentaire de la france a
sauvé la nage et ikea souveraineté
alimentaire ce sont les piliers de notre
liberté si nous n'avons plus à une livre
et je souhaite que la france
autre idée défendue dans les travées du
salon celle du communiste fabien roussel
le candidat pcf demande lui la création
d'une conférence nationale sur la
filière céréalière afin d'assurer la
sécurité des prix pour les agriculteurs
à ce que le président de la république
le gouvernement
engage rapidement une conférence
nationale
avec l'ensemble de la filière céréalière
afin d'assurer une sécurité des prix en
matière de céréales mais aussi une
sécurité des prix pour l'alimentation du
bétail puisque cette ce conflit cette
guerre aux portes de l'europe va vous va
avoir a déjà des conséquences fortes
sur les prix du blé et des produits
dérivés du blé le chef de l'état avait
coupé l'herbe sous le pied de tous les
candidats sur le thème de la
souveraineté alimentaire en inaugurant
le salon emmanuel macron avait annoncé
un plan de résilience pour sécuriser les
filières au niveau national et européen
et pour débattre autour de ceux de cette
question de la souveraineté alimentaire
toujours ici depuis le pavillon 4 du
salon de l'agriculture j'accueille
marion guillou bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes ancienne présidente de l'inra
et l'institut national de recherche pour
l'agriculture l'alimentation et
l'environnement membre du haut conseil
pour le climat emmanuel ducrocq bonsoir
journalistes à l'opinion bienvenue
bienvenue également à thierry pouch
bonsoir bonsoir chef économiste aux
chambres d'agriculture de paris matthieu
croissandeau évidemment est resté à mes
côtés marion guillou 7 cette notion de
souveraineté alimentaire et est ce que
vous n'avez pas un peu oublié en france
et est ce qu elle n'est pas réapparue
finalement grâce je mets des guillemets
à la crise qu vide oui c'est certain
c'est à dire qu'en fait vous souvenez de
la réforme de la pac enfin la création
de la pac ans 60,2 s'il fallait donner à
manger aux européens donc à l'époque on
pensait à ce qu'on appelait alors la
sécurité alimentaire et puis courant
monde mondialisation aidant
spécialisation est dense circulation
encourager on avait oublié que ça
n'allait pas de soi et ce sont les
périodes de crise et deux périodes de
crise très récente la crise du coc vide
d'abord est là bien sûr cette invasion
d'ukraine qui remettent en haut de
l'agenda le sujet de la souveraineté
alimentaire pour moi c'est évidemment de
souveraineté alimentaire européenne dont
nous parlons et non pas seulement de
souveraineté alimentaire français lluis
à ce nous ça se joue à la dimension de
l'europe emmanuel ducrocq et ont produit
tout juste ce que l'on consomme c'est
c'est à peu près ça le constat le
constant en france on est autour est
beaucoup plus exportateurs oui alors ça
dépend de quelle filière on parle à sion
de la filière des céréales on exporte à
peu près la moitié de ce qu'on produit
donc on a une filière qui est dynamique
et qui a son utilité dans notre
souveraineté mais aussi dans la
stabilité de tout le bassin
méditerranéen et ça c'est vraiment une
donnée qu'il faut avoir en tête c'est
qu'il y à aussi la sécurité du bassin
méditerranéen qui dépendent nos
productions après selon les filières
c'est très variable par exemple les
filières fruits et légumes ont beaucoup
souffert ces dernières années d'un
manque de compétitivité de normes très
dur et on importe aujourd'hui à peu près
la moitié des fruits et des légumes avec
des variantes selon les variétés on a
des aberrations dans notre système
alimentaire par exemple ont produit des
pommes de terre en france bien assez
pour nous mais on va les transformer à
l'étranger parce qu'on a plus les
structures de transformation et pour la
viande c'est un peu bizarre on a des
animaux qui partent être transformé en
grèce et en italie puis qui nous
reviennent pareil pour les porcs qui
nous reviennent sous forme de
charcuterie donc si vous voulez on
la france reste un pays très exportateur
mais elle a perdu de sa puissance et de
ses parts de marché à l'intérieur de son
bassin naturel c'est à dire l'europe on
va évidemment parler du blé des engrais
thierry pouch mais s il ya beaucoup
d'autres produits sur lesquels on est
dépendant aujourd'hui
la première dépendance qu'on observe
statistiquement est historiquement c'est
la dépendance aux protéines végétales et
depuis le début des années 60 on avait
signé en europe un accord avec les
etats-unis pour notre approvisionnement
en tourteaux de soja cet accord est
toujours en vigueur d'une certaine
manière et cette dépendance au soja et
aux protéines végétales en général n'a
pas pu être surmontés malgré les plan
protéines qui ont été adoptés depuis les
années 70 et aujourd'hui la question se
pose étant donné qu'il ya eu la crise
que vit d'aujourd'hui la crise
ukrainienne nous montre que nous sommes
dépendants de l'ukraine pour les
tourteaux de tournesol par exemple donc
là c'est un point évidemment névralgique
pour l'agriculture française et pour
l'élevage en particulier
donc ça veut dire qu'on peut manquer de
tourteaux tournesol dans l'est dans les
prochaines semaines on peut manquer de
tout autre tournesol dans les prochaines
semaines si les ports continue à être
bloquée durablement on va parler du
évidemment un grand chapitre de ceux de
ce débat autour de du blé du blé russe
de cet atout stratégique quelques
chiffres pour poser le décor le poids de
la russie dans le marché du blé premier
exportateur mondial entre 18 et 20% des
exportations mondiales 11 % de la
production mondiale source chambre
d'agriculture et puis l'évolution ça
c'est aussi intéressant de voir
l'évolution de la production de blé
russe sur 20 ans ça correspond à la
durée du pouvoir poutinien 2001 36
millions de tonnes de blé on est
aujourd'hui à 80 millions de tonnes dont
35 millions exportés
emmanuel ducrocq je joue ce chapitre
avec vous vladimir poutine a voulu faire
du blé un atout stratégique on peut
clairement dire ça oui il a fait il là
il a fait comme le font tous les chefs
d'état c'est à dire qu'il a regardé
quels étaient les atouts de son pays il
a ainsi sa puissance sur l'armement sur
l'énergie et sur l'agriculture si la
puissance russe
céréalière c'est autant des bleus c'est
autant développer c'est parce que il ya
eu d'une part des investissements mais
c'est aussi parce que le changement
climatique à donner à la russie une
nouvelle façon de cultiver ses terres
c'est à dire qu'avant aux plantes et des
blés de printemps beaucoup beaucoup plus
parce qu'on les plantes est après les
gelées mais comme les gelées se sont
faites plus rares on peut planter des
blés d'hiver qui ont des rendements bien
supérieur c'est de l'agronomie c'est un
peu technique mais sa crise puis conçoit
que si l'explosion de la production
voilà est alors 7,7 ses tonnages de blé
surnuméraires sont devenus une vraie âme
géopolitique pour la russie c'est à dire
qu'elle s'en sert pour dialoguer
diplomatiquement avec l'egypte notamment
qui dépend beaucoup du blé russe avec
une partie du moyen-orient avec le liban
avec certains pays d'asie et aujourd'hui
on le voit la russie est en train de
lier des alliances commerciales sur le
blé avec la chine elle a établi un
nouveau terminal ferroviaire non loin de
la frontière chinoise et on sait que le
blé s'il ne trouve pas preneur ailleurs
s'il ne peut plus traverser la mer noire
il partira en chine qui en est très
friande et qui en a un grand besoin donc
oui effectivement c'est une arme
diplomatique géopolitique au sens
presque
défensif du terme militaire du terme
marion guillou si si on rentre dans le
détail effectivement les pays les plus
dépendants du blé russe on l'a déjà un
peu évoqué gérard larcher en parlait
d'ailleurs lui aussi tout à l'heure si
on doit faire la liste le c'est surtout
le tour de la méditerranée ça donc et en
plus il faut savoir que ce sont des pays
qui en ce moment des stocks assez bas
donc qu'ils vont être très dépendant à
court terme des prix des céréales et on
est tous un peu inquiet de ce qui se
passait dans cette zone du monde dans
l'est dans les semaines et les mois à
venir oui parce que c'est un risque
pendant nous interrompre de
déstabilisation
socialiste c'est tout le monde repenser
à 2008 bien sûr c'est à dire c'est en
risque si les gouvernements laisser les
prix des céréales augmente et librement
au cours mondial c'est un risque
d'émeutes de la faim comme on en a connu
en 2008 donc il faut absolument
surveiller la situation dans ça il faut
que les gouvernements de ces pays
surveille la situation alimentaire de
très près ou de déception majeure ou de
déstabilisation politique qu'on a connu
ensuite avec les printemps arabes 1 sur
la vie chère est sûr qu'il a pourrait
concerner tout le bassin méditerranéen
oui c'est ça c'est à dire qu'en fait on
sait que toute la rive sud de la
méditerranée n'est pas autosuffisante en
production céréalière qu'elle importe
est donc vous l'aviez répéter tout à
l'heure où le président du sénat l'a
répété on sait que russie + ukraine
c'est à peu près 30% de la circulation
mondial des céréales donc cette zone qui
est déstabilisée soit par la production
soit du fait des ports et des moyens de
transport et c'est ça devient un
problème méditerranéen un problème
stratégique sur les engrais je vais vous
donner la parole tout de suite
thierry pouch quelques chiffres là aussi
le marché mondial des engrais la russie
ses 16 % du commerce mondial et la part
de la russie dans les importations
européennes l'anglais c'est 25% là aussi
c'est un peu toujours la même question
mais elle est allée centrale quel est
notre degré de dépendance aux engrais
russe aujourd'hui
on importe
essentiellement des engrais de russie
mais aussi d'ukraine un petit peu quand
même oui
et il faut aussi avoir à l'esprit que
ces engrais sont fabriqués à partir de
gaz pour l'essentiel est que nous sommes
donc assez dépendant dans l'union
européenne du gaz russe c'est 40 % des
approvisionnements c'est un peu moins
pour la france et 6% mais tout de même
donc si vous voulez il ya une
combinaison de facteurs qui risquent
d'aggraver les coûts de production des
agriculteurs
pour se procurer des engrais à la fois
par la flambée des prix du gaz qui se
répercute sur le prix des engrais et
aussi sur les disponibilités qui va y
avoir parce que hees a rejoint le thème
de votre émission en termes de
souveraineté nous ne sommes pas
souverain en engrais ce qui veut dire
qu'il faudrait relocaliser la production
d'engrais en france avec toutes les
difficultés que ça représente pourquoi
quelles sont ces difficultés alors des
difficultés en termes de temps de durer
il faut investir et puis il faut pas
oublier que l'épisode azf à toulouse a
quand même marqué les esprits donc il
sans parler de ce qui s'est passé au
liban aussi d'envoyer que l'aller les
usines d'engrais sont quand même très
contrainte et on a du mal à envisager
pour l'instant des phénomènes de
relocalisation donc on resterait
dépendant avec des engrais qui sur
l'année 2021 c'est à dire avant le
déclenchement du conflit ukrainiens
avaient déjà augmenté en france de 138%
donc en termes est ce qui peut
contrecarrer du coup la flambée des prix
des céréales d'un autre côté c'est le
syndrome fameux syndrome nimby not in my
backyard pas de ça chez moi
manuel ducrocq ça chez moi et en plus on
est confronté à une série assez
particulières en france en ce moment
c'est qu'il y avait une mission
d'information après le silo du liban sur
le stockage des engrais en france et on
était en train d'interdire ou en tout
cas de contraindre fortement le stockage
des engrais c'est ça s'est produit juste
avant la crise russe donc en fait on
était aussi dans une idée qu'on allait
réduire considérablement les capacités
de stockage en france et tout ça et
finalement complètement bouleversée
c'est à dire que la leur surgissement de
la thématique de la souveraineté
alimentaire dans notre débat public de
manière vraiment crû de manière vraiment
vital est en train de balayer beaucoup
de certitudes et beaucoup de pistes
qu'on avait emprunté avec notre
agriculture jusqu'au là justement je
vais juste vous poser une question de
béotien sur les engrais 100 en grèce a
fait baisser de combien le roman tout
dépend des cultures mais il faut
regarder simple au double c regardez le
bio regardez le bio on est on est sur
des tassements de rendement assez
conséquent
là l'objectif de la commission
européenne à travers sa stratégie ferme
tout fort qu on montre qu'il ya des
baisses de rendement qui pourrait aller
de 10 à 15% sur certaines cultures donc
on peut évidemment faire un usage dose
et économe des intrants mais sortir
complètement des engrais dans un pack
temps relativement bref ça c'est une
mission quasi impossible
alors je vous redonner la parole tout de
suite mais on rejoint quentin quel mec
est avec nous qui est en duplex en
direct depuis les allées de ce salon
dans le dans le hall 1 quentin pour
relayer peut-être les inquiétudes de
plusieurs secteurs notamment avec
jean-françois la zouk et le président
d'inter céréales exactement thomas parce
que on l'a compris dans votre débat avec
vos invités on le voit tous les regards
se tournent vers les céréaliers s'ils
vont mal cela aura un impact mécanique
sur beaucoup d'autres filières la france
on l'a compris également elle dispose
d'une bonne autonomie en matière de
fonctionnement de sa filière mais il n'y
a pas de problème d'importation
d'exportation plutôt des cours et des
marchés qui sont mondialisés donc
écouter effectivement jean françois
loiseau qui est le président de l'inter
céréales qui rassemble les producteurs
la collecte des céréales et les premiers
transformateurs des céréales
l'ukraine et la russie sont deux très
grands pays producteurs de céréales de
tournesol ou de colza la russie est
devenue le premier pays producteur de
blé en très très très peu de temps et ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est qu'à
cause de cette guerre la mer noire
sur laquelle il ya beaucoup de ports
d'exportation de céréales ne va pas
pouvoir sortir des bateaux pour aller
sur le bassin méditerranéen sur le
moyen-orient voilà et jean françois
loiseau qui parle d'une crise très grave
cité par étape celle qui pourrait de
plus en plus graves avec des pays qui
disposent parfois de trois semaines
seulement de stocks on l'a entendu aussi
dans les intervenants en plateau thomas
cette désorganisation des filières du
secteur primaire elle va mécaniquement
avoir des répercussions chez les
transformateurs des produits et un
moment où les coûts des matières
premières elles étaient déjà au milieu
de négociations très difficiles très
âpres avec les distributeurs ecoutez
jean moreau qui est directeur général de
la fédération de l'industrie laitière
qui rassemble des marques comme lactel
président ou danone qui chamboule tout
le set cette crise ukrainienne sur les
le cours d de l'énergie vient remettre
en cause tout ce qu'on avait pu essayer
de mettre en avant pour aller chercher
la valeur pour permettre aux producteurs
de lait et aux entreprises de vivre est
dressée sur les territoires et donc on a
un vrai souci là dessus mais ce n'est
pas que le problème de l'énergie qui
nous préoccupe il ya nos salariés en
ukraine et nos salariés en voient là
thomas a très rapidement pour évoquer
une dernière filière que nous avons
rencontrés depuis ce matin c'est la
filière porcine elle est déjà en
difficulté avait des exploitations qui
sont déjà déstabilisé depuis la pandémie
de kovy des également la fièvre porcine
africaine écouter thierry meyer qui est
le président de l'ina port ici au salon
depuis plus de six mois brady moins un
an l'alimentation animale avaient déjà
avait déjà augmenté de manière
considérable et on avait pris plus de
100 euros/tonne sur le blé est
en quelques heures et en quelques
quelques jours on est on a repris ça
s'est amplifié au niveau de
l'alimentation animale et hier en à côté
par exemple à 344 euros la tonne et les
productions animales sont très impactées
par les cours des céréales est
aujourd'hui si on prend un cours du porc
le cours du porc
le prix de revient du port c'est 80 %
liés à l'alimentation animale on voit là
thomas pour ses inquiétudes un dernier
mot pour vous dire que il y avait des
négociations sur le prix à des
négociations qui ont lieu tous les ans
qui se termine au moment du sang
l'agriculture elles viennent donc de se
terminer avec beaucoup de difficultés
dans certaines de ces filières et on
nous dit qu'elles sont déjà caduc à
cause de la crise en ukraine merci quand
on vous retrouve évidemment s'il
yad'autres d'autres informations notre
message à faire passer depuis les allées
du salon marion guillou vous ne l'avez
dit tout à l'heure là c'est cet enjeu
c'est enjeu de souveraineté alimentaire
et se joue au niveau de l'europe mais
est ce que la crise qu'on est en train
de vivre ne remets pas en cause tout
simplement le vieux modèle de
d'agriculture qui existe depuis des
décennies en france et en europe
d'abord en tant que citoyen on constate
que l'europe est là et qu'elle est plus
plus importante qu'avant et au niveau
agricole l'europe c'est extrêmement
important c'est la première politique
européenne pour l'instant l'agriculture
toujours et c'est bien après la guerre
les gens veuillent fin et c'était leur
priorité de manger à leur faim que les
agriculteurs est une existence digne
puisque c'était un double objectif pour
les agriculteurs et pour les
consommateurs alors est ce que l'europe
de fait l'europe et la bonne échelle
quand on parle de spécialisation quand
on parle transformation vous parliez des
pommes de terre elles vont se faire
transformer en belgique c'est peut-être
normal que lier des gains d'échelle et
que les pommes de terre face quelques
kilomètres pour aller se faire
transformer en belgique c'est
écologiquement c'est s'est pas
totalement un très grand mais bon c'est
pascal plus loin au delà des noms mais
il faut aussi penser que le consommateur
cherche à voir des aliments pas trop
cher et donc le principe de
spécialisation au niveau européen peut
se jouer dans la mesure où nous nous
sentons dans la même unité politique et
nous nous sentons solidaires en fait c
c'est ce qui se joue en ce moment et
c'est sans doute ce qui est en train de
progresser à vitesse grand v malgré nous
et du fait de ce drame une craignant
donc pour moi oui c'est toujours
l'europe qui est la bonne échelle pour
penser la politique agricole et
alimentaire etc au niveau européen qu'il
faut qu'on s'interroge sur nos
dépendances et je pense que c'est
extrêmement important de continuer
l'analyse qui a été commencé dire sur
quels produits sommes nous dépendons de
pays extra européens de quelques
opérateurs et donc fragile et il ya une
étude qui a été faite là-dessus il ya
des vaccins vétérinaires il y à des
acides aminés dont il ya des produits
pour l'alimentation animale il ya un
certain nombre de produits extrêmement
précis sur lesquels nous sommes très
dépendants et c'est dangereux quand nous
savons que le monde devient plus
difficile c'est dangereux de dépendre de
l'étranger sur des produits vitaux d'où
l'importance de réfléchir cette
souveraineté alimentaire au niveau
européen est effectivement l'a pas fait
depuis longtemps
changement de modèle ou pas emmanuel
deux crocs c'est une vraiment une très
bonne question et je pense qu'on n'a pas
encore la réponse mais on avait pris une
orientation stratégique en europe qui
était la déclinaison agricole du green
deal sa salle appelle la stratégie farm
to fork à grands traits ça consistait à
comment dire à appliquer des transitions
agroécologiques assez rapide à couper de
moitié les les utilisation d'engrais et
de produits phytosanitaires c'est
peut-être un peu moins de jeu j'ai plus
le chiffre en tête mais enfin aller
couper drastiquement a augmenté beaucoup
les jachères de l'ordre de 10% pour
comment dire minimiser l'empreinte
écologique de l'europe dans la
production alimentaire mais on se rend
compte que ça se traduisait par des
chutes de production vraiment
impressionnante sur certaines filières
10 à 15% globale des volumes de
nourriture mais peut-être 20% sur les
céréales et sam et l europe dans une
position de dépendance accrue c'est à
dire que les exportations vers le bassin
méditerranéen globalement c'était fini
et on se rendait compte qu'il y avait
beaucoup de choses qu'on allait importer
par ailleurs pour des motifs sans doute
très louable écologique mais on se rend
compte que dans le climat actuel tout ça
devient vraiment très comment dire à
remettre à plat clairement parce que la
donne géopolitique a changé parce que
l'alimentation c'est une donnée
stratégique c'est vital ce continent a
oublié que la la comment dire la
souveraineté alimentaire ce qui consiste
à choisir son destin alimentaire c'est
une construction ça ne nous est pas
tombé comme ça tout cuit dans le bec
pardon pour l'expression mais c'est 60
ans de travail en europe de politique
concertée alors avec des distorsions de
concurrence avec des sur transposition
mais avec quand même un objectif de
nourrir la population qui était un peu
abandonné et qui peut être va revenir au
premier plan thierry pouch sûr sur cette
question de modèle il ya un autre
élément qui est intéressant c'est les
difficultés du
marché du bio dire qu'on voit que les
finalement les consommateurs ils se
ruent moins sur le bio depuis quelques
mois voire depuis un ou deux ans que
dans les années précédentes alors là il
ya un principe de réalité d'une certaine
façon là aussi il ya surtout une réalité
économique s'est s'imposé à
l'agriculture biologique il y avait
effectivement une perspective très
prometteuse pour le développement de
l'agriculture biologique il y avait une
attente sociétale et puis la crise
sanitaire est intervenue avec évidemment
les confinements donc on consommer un
peu moins on a les moins dans les
magasins etc mais surtout il ya eu cette
crise économique qui a stabilisé
l'évolution du pouvoir d'achat
finalement et que les consommateurs se
sont rendus compte que le prix du bio
était beaucoup plus élevé qu'il y avait
une offre de produits alimentaires qui
était sensiblement similaire au bio les
produits estampillés haute valeur
environnementale tous les toutes les
indications géographiques les signes de
qualité et ils ont demandé à ce que
finalement le bio apporte la preuve que
l contribuer finalement à la réduction
du de la crise climatique et donc on est
dans une phase de sous consommation de
produits issus de l'agriculture
biologique qui finalement engorge le
marché et provoque des tassements de
prix des déclassements notamment en laye
mais il n'ya pas que cette filière là et
donc il ya une vraie interrogation là
dessus je voudrais juste ajouter un
point sur la souveraineté à l'échelle
européenne
c'est fondamentalement posée la question
d'une perspective d'une europe fédérale
finalement parce qu'aujourd'hui on voit
bien qu'il ya encore quelques
divergences sur l'idée de souveraineté
entre des pays du nord plutôt orienté
vers le libre échange et donc
s'approvisionner à l'extérieur et des
pays plutôt du sud qui sont quand même
arc bouté sur cette idée de souveraineté
dont qu'il a il ya un enjeu il ya un
défi considérable pour l'union
européenne de définir une souveraineté
alimentaire qu'ils soient ancrés dans
une europe fédérale au point de changer
son sa forme
un mental et même quand ça vous fait
réagir oui parce qu'on a eu un petit
laboratoire de ce que ça donne un pays
qui n'a pas pris soin de sa souveraineté
alimentaire le royaume uni a fait le
choix de dépendre du reste du monde pour
son alimentation il importe un peu plus
de la moitié de ses besoins alimentaires
et on a vu quand il n'a plus vraiment
d'agriculture très variés et on a vu
quand il est sorti de l'union européenne
que ça a posé beaucoup de problèmes et
et on a eu des rayons vie mais on a eu
des productions appauvri etc il faut que
le royaume uni se reconstruise se
reconstruisent une agriculture ou qu'il
ait source et ailleurs beaucoup plus
loin sur la planète ski coq qui pose
quand même des questions d'empreinte
environnementale de son alimentation
donc voilà on peut être que la vraie
leçon est la triste leçon de tout ça
c'est qu'il faut se prendre soin de cet
atout l'europe c'est une terre bénie des
dieux par son sol par son climat qui a
déjà des pratiques qui ont beaucoup
évolué et qui sont beaucoup plus
vertueuse qu'elle l'était auparavant il
faut considérer qu on a là un atout
stratégique avec notre agriculture avec
notre alimentation et qu'il faut
cultiver cet atout alors dans ce débat
consacré aux conséquences de de la
guerre en ukraine sur l'agriculture on
est on est toujours évidemment direct du
du salon de l'agriculture
il ya la question du marché russe parce
que là aussi un chiffre qui nous vient
de l'association française de
l'agro-industrie anja la france est le
neuvième fournisseur de la russie en
produits agroalimentaires ça représente
780 millions d'euros par an
marion guillou on peut imaginer que le
secteur agricole français va souffrir
dans son ensemble de cette perte les
marchés comment vous l'analysez ça
d'abord tout à l'heure j'avais envie de
réagir passe alors allez-y rapidement
mais s'il nous reste un peu attendre
parce qu'on peut quand même faire mieux
on peut utiliser mieux les engrais on
n'est pas obligé de laisser des nitrates
en excès on n'est pas obligé donc on
peut beaucoup amélioré la manière de
faire la précision ce qu'on appelle dans
tout le salon l'agriculture de précision
la goutte d'eau qui va au bon endroit
l'engrais qui appliquaient à bonn à bon
escient donc c'est pas je veux dire
c'est pas le modèle naïf contre le
modèle on parle notamment de
l'agriculture de précision oui bien sûr
il ya des moyens qui permet il ya des
moyens tels prix s'ils donnent dans le
trio qui permettent de faire mieux et
donc on utilisera moins d'engrais je
dire on est capable et ces dernières
années la consommation d'engrais n'a pas
arrêté diminuer certes lentement mais
n'a pas arrêté diminué donc donc on est
capable de faire mieux c'est ce que je
voulais mais alors c'est dans les camps
dans les duels c'est une évidence pardon
voilà huit ans je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec avec avec marc guillou on
est toutes capables de faire mieux et on
le sait jouer aux logiques qui s'ouvre à
nous aussi voilà encore mieux alors je
repose la question sur le marché russe
oui ce que ça représente pour
l'agriculture française parce que ce
marché aujourd'hui il se ferme alors oui
ce marché se ferme cela dit
la france n'est pas si mal placé je dire
objectivement c'est pas marché majeur
pensais pas le marché numéro un pour
nous et ce qui va être très difficile
c'est surtout l'augmentation du prix de
l'énergie je veux dire je pense que là
le problème immédiat pour les français à
gérer c'est l'augmentation du prix de
l'énergie et donc l'augmentation du prix
de l'engrais et du point de vue
géopolitique ces problèmes de tension
alimentaire au sud de la méditerranée je
pense pas que le problème numéro un pour
l'instant ce soit le débouché sur le
marché russe de toutes les façons depuis
le l'annexion de la crimée les sanctions
européennes et américaines
ça s'est traduit par des mesures de
rétorsion adoptée par moscou et
notamment le fameux embargo qui est
toujours en vigueur et qui a comment
plomber un certain nombre de filières
françaises les produits laitiers et le
fromage en particulier la viande porcine
les fruits et légumes donc là avec la
crise ukrainienne et les nouvelles
sanctions ça risque d'aggraver un
processus qui est engagée depuis 2014
d'où l'importance d'un d'un quoi qu'il
en coûte agricole d'où l'importance d'un
quoi qu'il en coûte mais jusqu'à quand
dans quelle mesure on va aller encore
plus loin que ce qui a été fait sachant
que l'état est quand même
structurellement d'été maintenant ce qui
n'est pas le cas de la russie justement
qui va pouvoir à hauteur de 12 %
d'endettement public comparativement à
nous à 120% il va pouvoir justement
débloquer suffisamment de crédit pour
soutenir un certain nombre de secteurs
dont celui de l'agriculture qu'est ce
qu'on peut attendre en la matière est ce
que effectivement ça a été l'un des
thèmes de notre premier débat mais je
veux bien vous entendre là dessus et
daniel ducrocq sur la phrase de marine
le pen qui était dans les allées du
salon il ya quelques heures dix ans les
agriculteurs ont pas vu l'ont pas vu le
quoi qu'il en coûte
je suis pas certaine qu'il n'ait pas vu
le quoi qu'il en coûte c'est quand même
un secteur qui s'est mobilisée
considérablement qui a dû se remettre en
ordre de marche avec des équipes
réduites qui a dû repenser toutes ces
chaînes de deux femmes de fabrication je
sais pas dans quel sens elle dit n'a pas
vu le quoi qu'il en coûte inapte à bélie
qui n'ont pas touché les aides
ya une partie du plan de relance qui est
destiné à la modernisation à
l'innovation en agriculture
donc non je pense que ce qu'elle a dit a
été un peu vite dit sur les 100
milliards du premier plan de relance il
y en avait 1 milliard 2 qui était dédiée
à l'agriculture et le secteur agricole
est inscrit dans le plan de relance 2030
donc alors on parle évidemment et c'est
normal on est on est au coeur du salon
de l'impact de cette de cette guerre sur
les rémunérations la situation les
importations des agriculteurs mais nous
consommateurs thierry pouch on va
forcément être impacté en bout de chaîne
y'a pas de il n'y a pas d'autre
possibilité
la problématique de la répercussion des
flambées de prix sur le consommateur
était déjà engagé depuis l'année
dernière d'où le thème de du pouvoir
d'achat dans cette campagne électorale
bien évidemment donc là si on a une
flambée du prix du blé tout à l'heure il
était question de 340 euros dans votre
repassage on est aujourd'hui à 350 euros
la tonne donc on a déjà progressé donc
inévitablement il y aura des
répercussions sur les produits
transformés à moins que dans une
perspective d'intervention de l'état on
pourrait pratiquer justement comme le
font les argentins ou les russes une
taxation des exportations pour retenir
les disponibilités sur le territoire
national et faire pression sur les prix
essayer de desserrer cette pression sur
les prix donc ça peut être une
perspective mais inévitablement la
question de l'inflation des produits
alimentaires va se poser dans les
semaines et les mois qui viennent taxer
les exportations qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette idée réelle du coup
c'est toujours un jeu à double à double
tranchant parce que si on taxe par
exemple nos exportations de céréales
vers le bassin méditerranéen
on s'est déjà rendu compte la semaine
dernière où il ya peut-être deux
semaines que l'egypte avait fait un
appel d'offres pour acheter du blé
qu'elle a annulé parce qu'ils étaient à
un prix trop élevé qu'elle ne pouvait
pas se l'offrir et le blé a depuis pris
quelque chose comme 50 euros la tonne et
donc elle peut encore moins se l'offrir
donc si on commence nous à renchérir les
exportations vers ces pays là on va
garder pour nous une certaine forme de
stabilité mais on va les déstabiliser
complètement avec ce que sa robe comme
conséquence pour nous c'est à dire des
migrations probablement donc en fait
tous à cesser ce sont des effet de
domino dans ce monde alimentaire
interconnecté quand on touche un des
petits boutons ont fait bouger tous les
autres donc il faut vraiment bien pensé
aux effets que aux effets que tout cela
à quand la russie a décidé de mettre des
quotas sur ses exportations elle a
participé à l'augmentation des cours du
blé si les cours du bien on commençait à
monter ces derniers mois c'est parce que
la russie a retenu une partie de ses
stocks pour elle en les taxant
depuis 2018 quand même la fao rappelle
donc avant qu vide pendant qu vide et
maintenant avec la guerre russo
ukrainienne que l'insécurité alimentaire
est en train d'euros se redresser donc
il faut aussi tenir compte de ça un pays
comme l'afghanistan est en train de
mourir de faim en silence parce qu'ils
n'ont même plus les moyens d'acheter
quelques tonnes de blé pour nourrir leur
population qu'est ce que ça suppose
comme comme réforme marion guillou ce
qui est très intéressant c'est de
constater que l'organisation mondiale du
commerce qui tous à une époque était là
pour éviter les mesures protectionnistes
maintenant elle réglemente justement les
empêchements les barrières à
l'exportation cirque elle empêche les
pays de garder pour eux au lieu de
demander aux pays de ne pas se protéger
on a complètement inverser la logique du
commerce mondial
c'est à dire qu'on limite on observe
limite les pays qui mettent des
barrières aux exportations alors
qu'avant vous souvenez bien que toute la
doctrine de l'om sait c'était de faire
tomber les barrières à l'importation
on allait la logique de l'offre et la
demande au niveau mondial a complètement
été inversés cyril fouche c'est très
important ça ce qui vient d'être rappelé
par marion guillou parce que dans la
thématique de la souveraineté c'est une
brèche dans la mondialisation qui s'est
ouverte lundi
il va falloir reconsidérer
l'organisation de l'économie
internationale
et il faut la repenser en pensant à
l'agronomie c'est à dire que si on
exporte des céréales si un commerce
mondial des céréales c'est parce que la
culture des céréales elle et elle est
contrainte par la géographie par le
climat en dessous du 50e entre le 25e et
le 50e degrés de latitude on peut faire
du blé ailleurs c'est très compliqué et
c'est pas de la mauvaise volonté ou
c'est pas de la cepa de la nullité agro
logique pardon agronomique c'est juste
que c'est pas possible donc en fait tout
ça va s'amplifier avec le changement
climatique avec la réalisation de
nouvelles zones nos qui va falloir
repenser la matière la manière dont on
cultive mais faut pas penser que le fait
de faire du commerce de céréales c'est
de la domination coloniale c'est aussi
parce que ça répond à une demande très
matériel est très basique de choses qui
ne sont pas possible de produire sur
d'être produites sur place dans des pays
avec des démographies qui sont galopante
et donc en fait on a aussi cette
équation là je vais remercier thierry
pouch d'avoir participé à ce débat parce
qu'on va aussi accueillir tout de suite
merci beaucoup c'était c'était
passionnant merci d'être venu sur notre
plateau au coeur de
du salon du pavillon 4 de ce salon de
l'agriculture on accueille tout de suite
stéphane sotra bonsoir bienvenue et
bravo stéphane fautrat puisque vous êtes
le lauréat du prix spécial des
territoires mutualia public sénat alors
vous êtes agriculteur dans le loiret
c'est ça là où exactement alors tout à
fait dans le nord du loiret dans une
commune nouvelle qui s'appelle le mal
géré moi qu'en fait tu es à côté de
malesherbes des kills limitrophes avec
l'essonne et la seine et marne a alors
depuis combien de temps vous fait ce
métier et puis alors qu'est-ce que vous
produisez alors avec mon épouse nous
sommes accros agriculteurs depuis 1984
sur cette exploitation familiale voyez
donc ça fait déjà un nombre de décès ni
l'exploitation familiale ça veut dire
qu'avant vous dérouter nos parents nos
grands parents voilà donc depuis deux
siècles et produisons sur cette
exploitation pour répondre à votre
question
uniquement des productions végétales
c'est à dire du blé de l'orge de
brasserie des pommes de terre des
betteraves du tournesol du colza du soja
depuis peu de temps de la luzerne voilà
un assolement très diversifié comment
vous avez fait évoluer finalement votre
votre métier votre exploitation depuis
quelques années choix vous avez pris un
virage ya quoi il ya trois quatre ans
c'est là c'est pour cette raison que
vous avez parlé de ce prix que nous
avons obtenues ces
halles approche un peu de fans carrière
et quand
nos enfants indiquent qu'ils ne sont pas
intéressés qui n'ont pas envie d'être
agriculteur parce que tout à fait tout à
fait recevable et juste nous sommes posé
la question en 2018 avec mon épouse du
devenir de cette exploitation
au cours de notre vie professionnelle
comme souvent les agriculteurs nous
avons acheté au reste de la famille les
bâtiments souvent départ des parcelles
de terre du fossé donc petit à petit on
nous sommes devenus à être maître si
vous voulez de notre outil
professionnel
et à ce moment nous faisons c'est
question du devenir de cette
exploitation mais des fois quand tu un
peu un petit peu provoqué jeudi on
pourrait la vendre un investisseur
chinois par exemple ou bah oui
puisqu'elle nous appartient on fait des
voix un industriel il vend son
entreprise à quelqu'un d'autre et c'est
son choix voilà donc c'était une option
c'est de la vendre
dans sa globalité et de faire en fait ce
que nous voulions c'est une option nous
avons choisi une autre option qui est de
dire de toute façon l'agriculture et
l'alimentation et notamment aux portes
du grand paris mais aussi ailleurs
l'agriculture à l'alimentation des
décennies à venir ne sera pas la même
que celle des décennies passées voilà
le rapport à l'alimentation du citoyen
le rapport à l'environnement et aux
questions environnementales de citoyens
sera pas les mêmes donc on dit vous avez
fait quoi vous êtes passé
comment vous êtes passés au bio mais pas
que c'est sympa d'avoir passé au bio on
fait un chemin un autre chemin oui nous
sommes dit il faut transformer sur place
nos productions
nous avons depuis des décennies
petit à petit perdu la maîtrise de la
valorisation de notre produit je le dis
aussi direct que ça
et ça ça crée un problème donc en fait
on va essayer d'attirer dans notre
exploitation beaucoup de bâtiments on a
on peut construire les bâtiments des
entrepreneurs qui auraient envie de
monter une activité transformation des
productions que nous faisons sur notre
ferme ok combien c'est ce que vous êtes
impliqué avec c'est quoi ces on appelait
on parle souvent de tir lieu c'est 1 0
on a commencé à faire autre chose savez
ça viendra après et
nous avons on a une production qui est
très importante dans notre région que la
production d'orge de brasserie oui tout
notre territoire est réputé le hasard a
voulu le hasard on a un peu cherché que
nous rencontrons contre riom des jeunes
brasseurs parisiens qui ont créé une
marque qui s'appelle lbf la brasserie
fondamentale ils créent leur marque à
paris ils ont l'ordre 3 4 bars ils font
leurs petites recettes leurs gammes et
ça marche donc il cherche un endroit
pour installer leur brasserie vous allez
ouvrir une brasserie alors non mais
la bras si elle est ouverte déjà et elle
est ouverte donc en mai conduit on a
fait le chemin inverse c'est qu'en fait
ils nous ont dit nous on veut bien
travailler on veut bien venir chez toi
on la met toute la production de notre
brasserie scam cent mille bouteilles par
semaine actuellement toute la production
de notre brasserie lé bureau donc quand
je vous dis qu'on a fait le chemin
inverse compris et qu'on adapte notre
exploitation
à l'entreprise de transformation que
l'on a sur notre dans notre écosystème
c'est ça on fait on fait le chemin
inverse c'est à dire que on ne se lance
pas dans la production de l'agriculture
biologique sans avoir le client en fait
c'est un peu on sait que c'est risqué on
sait que c'est difficile c'est pas du
tout le même métier voilà donc il faut
se former il faut que les jeunes qui
travaillent avec moi voilà donc on a
fait ça ouais alors ça m'intéresse
d'avoir votre rond on est dans un débat
sur la souveraineté alimentaire est ce
que vous vous sentez concerné par
exemple pour parler des engrais est ce
que est ce que c'est un c'est un enjeu
pour vous est ce que vous vous importez
des engrais ou alors est-ce que vous en
avez moins besoin parce que vous êtes
passés au bio c'est quoi votre il faut
aussi des fumeurs pour l'agriculture
biologique et ça a des débats qu'on a eu
un autre endroit il ya quelques jours
notamment avec avec un manuel c'est
oui ça me soucie l'origine des engrais
ça me soucie ça me soucie sur le prix ça
me soucie aussi sur l'origine en
agriculteur à un peu militant mais c'est
le sujet qu'on a eu ce qu'ils viennent
de russie
si on va un petit peu plus loin oui
samsam souci ça me soucie aussi sur le
prix parce que les fumeurs ont les
engrais organiques ou les fumeurs qui
sont utilisés en agriculture biologique
sont déjà beaucoup plus cher que les que
les engrais pour l'agriculture
conventionnelle et sont beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus rares voilà donc dans les
dents les dents les coûts de revient en
fait des produits ça ça a toute son
importance mais mais tout ça me soucie
bien entendu mais
match on est en fait notre démarche
notre schéma c'est une relocalisation en
fait nous on se dit on s'est dit avec et
avec les générations un nouvel qui
travaillent avec nous nous avons 15
millions de consommateurs à notre porte
j'ai en fait notre exploitation elle a
61 kilomètres du centre de paris alors
c'est vrai que c'est une particularité
nous nous disons nous avons 15 millions
de consommateurs on va essayer d'en
nourrir quelques-uns
avec ce qu'ils attendent voilà c'est ça
l'idée donc au delà du du bio même si à
la logique de circuits courts vous
pouvez répondre à une demande de
circuits courts pour des consommateurs
parisiens par exemple moins 24 heures
c'est l'étape d'après c'est à dire que
vous avez parlé de l'éco lieu c'est que
nous répondons à un appel à projets de
la région centre val de loire ce que
nous sommes dans la région centre val de
loire pour la création d'un éco lieu
tiers lieu à côté de la brasserie qui
aura notamment une épicerie de produits
de producteurs un espace de coworking et
ça attire les urbains oui et on est dans
la dans le circuit court
c'est intéressant le modèle du groupe à
ce qu'on est vraiment dans une
diversification dans un virage raisonnée
comment vous analysez le
le parcours de stéphane faudra le
parcours de stéphane c'est l'histoire de
l'agriculture française c'est à dire une
agriculture qui s'est toujours beaucoup
adapté à ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle avait
sous la main aux besoins fakih kia qui a
considérablement changé je sais pas si
il ya d'autres secteurs économiques en
france qui ont autant évolué que
l'agriculture au cours des décennies et
c'est l'histoire de stéphane c'est aussi
l'histoire d'une agriculture extrêmement
diverse et c'est aussi pour ça que
l'agriculture française et résistante
c'est que il faut des modèles comme
celui ci pour répondre à des clients de
proximité il faut aussi des grandes
exploitations parce qu'il ya des gens
qui n'ont pas les moyens d'avoir accès à
des produits qui coûtent sans doute un
petit peu plus cher que les autres il
faut que cette agriculture puisse
répondre aux besoins de tous les
français en quantité en qualité et c'est
ça qui est important dans la conception
de l'agriculture française c'est qu'il
n'y a pas un seul modèle qui peut
marcher il y en a beaucoup et je pense
que c'est fantastique de se dire que
chaque agriculteur peut déterminer le
projet qui lui plaisent celui dans
lequel il va se réaliser il ya des
céréaliers qui exporte des céréales et
qui sont très fiers de ce travail là
vous faites de la bière pour le pari
vous en être très fiers et vous avez
bien raison et il n'y a pas deux il n'y
a pas de cette agriculture voyez il n'y
a pas de sun agriculture il y a des
agricultures qui répondent aux besoins
et aux besoins des consommateurs alors
évidemment il faut faire toujours mieux
il faut faire toujours plus dans le
détail plus dans la précision etc mais
ça c'est un travail de fond que la
culture très habituel ou de marion
guillou oui ce qui m'intéressait
également dans votre danse que vous
décriviez c'est le mouvement vers les
engrais organiques
vous disiez que je suis membre du haut
conseil pour le climat et vous savez
peut-être que les engrais minéraux sont
beaucoup plus nocif pour les gaz à effet
de serre pour le pour ce qu'on appelle
le changement climatique que les engrais
organiques et donc qu'on va voir dans
les années qui viennent un mouvement
général vers les engrais organiques avec
ce que vous signaliez c'est là le besoin
d'avoir plus d'engrais organiques donc
d'utiliser les déchets des villes est à
nouveau ça va être un lien entre les
différents milieux d'utiliser plus tout
ce qui est des chais des industries
déchets ménagers déchets des villes pour
injecter 2 les engrais organiques
donc on trouve finalement une
convergence entre les différents
mouvements et ce que je voulais dire
aussi sur le bio c'est vous avez échappé
à ce problème mais le bio il faut que ce
soient plus payés que le reste puisque
le rendement est moins fort et ça ne
peut pas être autre chose qu'un marché
de niche sinon vous ne vous n'avez plus
la valeur ajoutée qu'il faut donc tout
le monde s'étonne du fait que les prix
du bio s'écroule mais c'est pas étonnant
c'est une question de quantité sur le
marché à vous le mot de la fin stéphane
faute non je vais juste à me dire une
petite chose c'est que nos bières les
biards que nous fabriquons ne vont pas
jouer seulement dans le grand paris mais
si vous prenez le tgv à la voiture
barbosa et nos bières si vous avez sur
air france transavia europe vous avez
nobiliaire pour ce temps freine encore
l'avion donc qu'on est oui mais mais
voilà et
par rapport à ce que disait madame
guillou l'instant c'est vraiment tout le
tout l'économie circulaire en fait qu'on
fait sur l'exploitation par exemple la
brasserie elle produit 300 tonnes de ce
qu'on appelle de drèches ce sont les
produits les issues enfin qui me veut
devenir des biscuits par exemple ils
peuvent devenir des biscuits mais
transformé 300 tonnes de drèches en
biscuit en février c'est en fait
beaucoup beaucoup alors vous en faites
quoi eh bien on fait de léon feix de
l'épandage dans les champs pour la
culture qui suit pour une autre culture
et ça moi je suis passionné par cette
par cette démarche merci beaucoup merci
à tous d'avoir participé à ce débat
c'était vraiment passionnant là c'est la
fin de de cette émission un grand merci
à toutes les équipes de public sénat
parce qu'une des loques comme on dit une
délocalisation c'est un vrai beau
travail collectif donc merci à tous
c'était une émission
nickel comme on dit